the Joe Rogan experience I don't know if
I want to like jerk off in between like
CNN and Business Insider I'd look at
Twitter so infrequently now cuz every
time I look at it it seems to be he's
fighting it's exhausting arguing you
don't help me cuz I was like this
special and I loved your special because
like you acknowledge you like I'm gonna
get in trouble for this like you're
gonna be so like that was just so
[ __ ] smart when I was writing this
special it's the first time I've ever
done one where I started cutting bits
because I was like it's just not worth
the fighting like I don't want to
[ __ ] deal with it you know like I had
this whole bit on Marilyn Monroe and how
I don't think she's like I feel like
she's being forced on us as like a
feminist icon like all my girlfriend's
like posting like photos of Marilyn
Monroe being like you know always show
up two hours late keep a man waiting I'm
like this woman is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
she's a slob and why do i why she's not
my Gloria Steinem and I just had this
whole bit and I'm just like oh they're
gonna say I don't like women and I'm
shaming slut-shaming I just like it's
not [ __ ] worth well she's a weird one
right because she [ __ ] everybody which
is not bad it's not bad to [ __ ]
everybody but she [ __ ] everybody and
apparently that's the real conspiracy is
that the Kennedys had her killed because
she was banging JFK and then she's
banging an RFK and apparently she loose
lips sink ships
yep just yappin a lot and look I I'm
gorgeous good for her for making my back
then making money the way you had to but
I just
let's let her be what she was why why
you know I think that she that hedy
lamarr should get the credit that she
gets you know I mean you talk about any
more [ __ ] jean badass she was a legit
Union nobody gives a [ __ ] responsible
for Wi-Fi people use Wi-Fi mostly to
Google Marilyn Monroe pose Patti Lamar
came back to life is like so did my
invention did it ever come of anything
we'd be like yeah good news bad news
yeah we mostly use it to Google the
[ __ ] version of you know I don't I
don't it's it's I love Marilyn Monroe I
like I just feel like there's this thing
now where you know women we can't
criticize any woman ever or else that we
get in trouble you know
and I think we have to be able to call
Pete like I say in my special I talk
about the difference between women that
are does anyone have any girlfriends
that think they're feminists but they're
actually just [ __ ] you know that's
so true and I know that I'm gonna get
[ __ ] for it